you know what I love most about this I'm
actually taller than someone I got this
alright there we go my first car of
course was in high school was in 1971
Mercury Marquis it was the family car
handed down to me by my parents it was a
giant boat I love this car I actually
got it up to 115 miles per hour once it
was unbelievable completely
uncontrollable I don't know if I should
be here today but the greatest thing I
ever did has actually got it airborne at
one point all four wheels off the ground
my childhood dream car had to be the 60s
Batmobile Adam West driving around that
thing it was awesome I got the
second-best thing I can keep that with
you without a doubt the car that gets
the most attention than I drive of
course the Batmobile but besides that
it's gonna be the Ford GT x1 I mean the
Ford GT I'll never forget that
commercial was Super Bowl I think it was
probably go 405 it was a red one
driving around that was an unbelievably
bad X commercial for badass car it's a
race car I think the worst car on the
road if you ask me this seven months ago
I would know emphatically it was a
Fisker I owned a Fisker it was horrible
got one of the first ones and I think in
six months the guy was out seven times
to work on the car I sold it that from
under it didn't lose anything and then
things started going horrible and then I
wanted the Fisker again because I knew
the company was gonna go out of the
business so I told my car guy I said
find me another Fisker just like that
one of the good ones one of the early
ones and he did he said the guy that's
selling number five said he'll sell it
to you nobody else but you need to call
him here's the phone number so I talked
to the guy for 30 minutes and I bought
the car from humble it was general Kolob
house
is there a car that I haven't driven
that's on my bucket list
well there was until about five months
ago it was the tumbler or my latest
Batman movies the only guys that get to
drive that our Batman or the stunt guy
or me if I was in the right place at the
right time it was frickin awesome hey
thanks for checking out my vehicles and
please subscribe to GQ comm you can see
more car collections right there